okay so the house of the Dragon finale
is now here and episode 10 brings a lot
with it the final episode is filled with
Easter eggs hidden details book
differences and things that set up where
season two is going you know the drill
by now full spoilers for the episode for
the first part of the video and if you
want to know what comes next in the
story then that will be in the end in
our super spoiler super spoiling section
it was at this moment that he knew he
[ __ ] up titled The Black Queen it sets
up renira is the leader of the group
that still hold their Oaths loyal to
viserys however as we've seen many still
believe that a man should sit on the
throne above all else and because of
this keeping allies becomes difficult
due to people having the bias that men
should lead this is seen most notably in
Lord boros who we meet at Storm's end
this location was shown all the way back
in episode 4 when Rainer went there to
pick out a suitable husband here we saw
her with Maurice's father Bowman who
died between 116 to 132 AC boros has
many dores and in the books he says that
if he were to die then Storm's end would
pass to a male so why should it be any
different when it comes to King's
Landing we'll get into that later on
with the kinsling becoming a major event
but you could say that the loser wasn't
that strong after all
now to lay out where we're at in the
story episodes one to a took place
during chapter 12 titled The Heirs of
the Dragon last week began with chapter
13 the blacks and the greens and this
episode continues that before going into
the Sun for the sun chapter that
immediately follows it similar to the
episode the rest of chapter 13 takes
place on Dragonstone and we go there
whilst the cheers for egg and ring out
unlike the show his coronation wasn't
interrupted by rhaenys and it was more
of a happy event with the greens taking
a clear win the work says sir arakargil
LED his grace into the torchless throne
room where egg on the second mounted the
steps of the Iron Throne before a
thousand Lords and knights shouts rang
through the hall run Dragonstone no
cheers were heard instead screams echo
through the hordes and stairwells of sea
dragon Tower down from the Queen's
apartment where anira Targaryen strain
and shuddered in her third day of Labor
the child had not been due for another
turn of the Moon with the tidings of
King's Landing had driven the princess
into a black Fury and her age seemed to
bring for the bed as if the Babe inside
were angry too and fighting to get out
this episode is a completely devastating
one for an era as she learns about the
loss of her father the throne and Beyond
this she also loses two children there's
a big and Swift thing that raniera will
know that do next season and all this
loss needs to be understood in order to
really see why her Arc goes the way it
does
now the episode itself begins with
luceris looking over the painted table
the Young Prince touches the location of
drift Mark which as we know he is the
heir of however due to the events that
happened in the episode he will never
get to inherit it he questions whether
he's worthy to take over Corliss who he
dubs as the greatest sailor who ever
lived he doesn't want drift Mark or to
become the heir but his mother says
he'll be strong enough to do it the
series is thematically about parents
pushing their own Wills on their
children how we've seen as people have
reluctantly taken them up either way
luceris will never get to see whether he
could have been a good lord of the tides
as he is snuffed out by aemond what I
love about this episode is that it
really shows the cost of war and how the
innocent die because of it luceris was
just a kid and he's clearly out of his
death this is seen early on in the scene
but it is something that's repeated
throughout the episode he's clearly best
in a sparring match with his brother and
I think this is supposed to mirror the
one that Eamon had with Kristen Cole it
shows the Gap in their ability and also
explains why lucerus gets out of Storms
and his quickly as he can he doesn't
want this war and he's no match for
what's to come so he goes out early on
which tips the dragon scales and the
Green's favor the painted table is a
piece that's appeared throughout the
Song of Ice and Fire law and I love this
opening pan showing all the kingdom it
was used by egg on the conquer and
ordered a plot out his plans of
domination throughout Westeros and it's
now being used by his great great great
granddaughter to do the same thing in
Game of Thrones it was used by Stannis
Baratheon and also Daenerys and several
characters have looked over this in
order to try and win obviously the show
needs to reign in how it's described in
the book but that lists it as being 50
feet long and 25 feet wide this contains
every major house and landmark and it
allows one to look over the entire realm
the table is lit underneath with fire
and this too carries meaning with it
there's an orange glow that now basks
the map and this represents the fire
that will rain down on the land once the
dragons start to rain down fire now from
Sir Lawrence we learn that princess
rhaenice has just arrived last week
obviously were there crashing the party
in the back of her Dragon malees who in
the book is nicknamed the Red Queen this
is very much reflected in herodoma which
has a chess piece filled with dragon
scales she's flown all the way from
King's Landing and if we look at the map
you'll see this is a direct flight of a
Blackwater Bay this is a key location
and due to the vast body of water
Corliss is eventually able to strangle
all important exports that go to King's
Landing in the book he was already
recovered from his fever at this point
when aegon usurped his sister and
chapter 14 opens by saying on driftmark
the sea snake ship set sail from Holland
spice town to close the gullet chugging
off Trey to and from King's Landing you
can totally see how this gives them a
strategic Advantage as the greens now
have to waste more time and money
navigating their trade through other
means by that that doesn't mean that
they're on the back foot I feel like
that the work says Old Town King's
Landing and landisport were the largest
and richest cities in the realm all
three were held by the greens every
visible symbol of legitimacy belonged
egg on he sat on the throne he lived in
the red keep he wore the conqueror's
crown wielded The conqueror's Sword and
had been anointed by the certain of the
faith before the eyes of tens of
thousands Grand maester Orwell sat in
his councils and the Lord commander of
the king's God had placed the crown upon
his princely head and he was male which
in the eyes of many made him the
rightful King his half-sister the
usurper now this video is sponsored by
established titles a gift that lets you
become like your favorite Lord a lady in
House of the Dragon did you know there's
a traditional Scottish custom to have
landowners referred to as a lord lady or
a lad that's why I was super interested
in this project which allows you to get
at least one square foot of dedicated
land in Edelson Scotland it's also a
great way to help out the environment as
established titles will plant one tree
with every single order they work with
Charities like one tree planet and trees
for the future to help with
reforestation efforts so if you pick up
a plot you can refer to yourself as a
lord whilst helping to preserve the
picturesque Woodlands of Scotland now
there also comes a bit of an ego boost
on top of all this environmental stuff
because you're now a lord ladder a lady
you can officially change your name on
things like credit cards plane tickets
your dating profile whatever you want to
do as you can see here they give you an
official certificate and also details
the exact location of your unique plot
number on top of this established titles
have also told me that the first 200
people who use my link below will be
placed within walking distance from my
plot depending on how many of you want
to become a lord lady a LED we can build
our unique heavy spoilerm Kingdom
together you can be like Lord Kevin
spoilers you punk I'll see you jump
established titles is actually running a
massive early Black Friday sale right
now plus if you use the code heavy
spoilers you get an additional 10 off go
to establishtitles.com heavy spoilers to
get your gift and help support the
channel makes for a great last minute
gift you can get yourself involved in
all the house of the Dragons drama so
definitely go check it out in the
description below thanks now rainey's
urgent only request an audience with
Damon and ranera and sadly she's the
bearer of bad news viserys is dead aegon
is the king and the finale leaked two
days early so it's all kicking off
interesting bit here is that Damon
suspects Allison made a viserys and this
is something that we wondered about in
episode 8. obviously he suspiciously
sniffed his cup and in his mind they'd
been sedating him whilst running their
own schemes and plans milk of the poppy
is basically similar to morphine and
though it helps with pain it also makes
someone easy to control the T was
clearly holding the SARS back too as
when he turned down the drink the time
that Otto offered it he ended up going
to the throne room he also had his
supper that night and it was only after
Alison gave him the tea again that he
ended up dying obviously the guy was on
his way out he would have died anyway
but I like that the show is at least
letting us theorists think that Damon
isn't completely crazy the tea is also
probably what made viserys think Alison
was raniera so them sedating him did
have its consequences Alison and Otto
are all clearly about control too and
not only do they sway the saris but I
also think they put egg on the throne
because he's gonna be easy to guide in
The Chariot last week Alison was very
much telling him what he needed to do
and she and her dad even had their own
teams trying to get him so that they
could force their will on him now Damon
saw dark sister is a really important
object as it ties into just how far the
family have fallen apart huge announced
a brain pilot for breaking this down and
he discussed how egg in II now holds the
conqueror's sword whereas Damon has this
during aegon's Conquest the pair fought
alongside one another with dark sister
being held by visenya who we'll talk
more about in just a bit originally they
were held by people fighting for the
same cause but then being on opposite
sides now shows how divided the houses
are now all this bad news at once proves
too much for an era and it triggers her
labor I think there's actually a line
here that pushes her over the edge the
greens are coming for you rhaenira
and for your children since episode 6
raniera has constantly been trying to
protect her children and this is evolved
over time initially it was them being
accused of being Strong's then it was
further accusations by vehemence and now
it seems like murder is on the courts
all proves too much and it pushes her
into premature labor like what might
happen if we get a general election
now the birth is described in full
detail in the book going over how
agonizing it is for an era at one point
she brings the wrath of Gods upon her
half brothers and their mother and she
also screams out monster to the child
though we get some details about what it
comes out like the book gives us a lot
more with her being described as twisted
and malformed we also learn there's a
hole in her chest where her heart should
be and she carries a stubbly and scale
tale similar to a dragon it's a really
heartbreaking moment in the story that
completely changes the playing field
with renera making her realize
everything that they've taken from her
her quote in the source material is she
was my only daughter and they killed her
they stole my crown and murdered my
daughter and they shall answer for it we
learned that the girl was going to be
called vicenia after one of egg on the
conqueror's Sister Wives she was a
writer of vegar who is now on the side
of the greens alongside aymond I love
how we get Quick Cuts of Cyrax whilst
this is going on and at times it was
thought that the dragons and their
Riders had an almost psychic-like
connection in in the case of drogon the
book even said that Dany could sense him
before he was born and that he used to
give her wisdom in her dreams now
elsewhere Damon starts to plot out a
plan with the other house leaders this
is a prototype of the Council of the
blacks and it involves people that still
hold their oats Damon actually takes two
nights of the king's God out shortly
after this scene and he threatens them
with caraxis alongside sir Lawrence is
darklin who will talk more about later
on in the video he's obviously been
betrayed by a lot of people and now
worries that if he doesn't lead with
Pierre then others will switch sides too
I absolutely love the design of
Dragonstone here and several of the
wolves and blocks look like Dragon Jaws
we also have the stones that appear like
scales and smoke and Mist lifting off
the ground as Lawrence at one point
wants to call Damon away from the
council in order to see his wife he asks
if he wants him to bring in a maester
and Damon already has first-hand
experience of what this could mean with
Elena Damon instead goes outside to
frighten the night and this is clearly
because he doesn't want to live through
that trauma again obviously the elephant
in the room is that this episode leaked
and I did see a number of reactions with
people saying that they hated how Damon
strangled rhaenyra honestly the guy
murdered his first wife so I do think
this was in character he's not really
meant to be likable and one of the main
reasons Otto forced his family down a
life of seizing power was to keep him
off their Throne he is a bad guy and
though you might find some parts of him
relatable doing stuff like this where he
intimidates the knights and also
strangles for nearer it just shows his
true character now the black Council was
dubbed this in the true telling the book
describes it as being an opposite of the
counter like King's Landing and here we
meet several people loyal to raniera the
book tells us that 30 nights a hundred
crossbow men and 300 men at Arms made up
the Garrison of Dragonstone on top of
this the work also notes that we had
several high-ranking members in
attendance this included saldagar of
claw Isle stoned in a rook's rest Massey
of stone dance bar Emin of sharp point
and darklin of duskendale amongst them
however the work says that the strongest
person to pledge their allegiance was
Corliss Valerian even though the DNA
tests show the grandkids aren't his and
even though Raymond lost his head a bit
when he was going off in their own room
he's still loyal to his ladies renice is
of course very much a mirror for an era
and the pair both had their Birthright
taken from them by someone who wasn't a
true Heir Bernice was jeharis's daughter
or as he passed the server to viserys
who wasn't a direct descendant same sort
of thing is kind of happening here and
the similarities in their Arc go beyond
just their names we know that yasaris is
sent to win a felon order to gain
craigenstock's hand and he's also
dispatched to Lady Jane Aaron of the
Airy bloody Airy shut the [ __ ] up Ryan
Airy that's a season two plotline Buddy
goes there in the book and she two
thinks that women are often overlooked
in favor of men you don't know who will
be cast as her but a while back you
might remember that there was talk of
Elizabeth Olsen potentially showing up
in season two who knows if it probably
isn't but there's lots of things that
happen while he's out at the location
which I'll talk more about at the end of
the video that's just to avoid spoilers
now after the child is stillborn ranera
wraps it up instead of the silent
sisters typically they would be the ones
who prepared the bodies for a funeral
but Ramirez is herself now the funeral
is a traditional Targaryen one with this
involving cremation really heartbreaking
scene and it shows just how much he's
lost they carry out the ceremony and
during this we see a young Joffrey now
grown up in the book he was his age when
Eamon lost his eye but the timeline has
been changed slightly with certain
things now at this point renera is
crowned with the same one viserys wore
throughout the season this was stolen
last week by Eric which differs slightly
from the book in that rather than being
burned along with his corpse Alison
ordered it locked away in the vault
which is when it was stolen by a servant
either way this Crown brings a lot with
it as it was worn by her father and also
King joharis rather these kings were
known for maintaining peace within the
realm and this symbolizes where an era
considers peace at one point she of
course had as the prophecy to deal with
two which had been passed down the line
like some medieval Chain Letter it's now
her responsibility to pass it on the
next king of Queen and because of this
we can see why aegon is illegitimate now
he carries the conqueror's crown which
is something that represents chaos this
showcases what he's brought to the realm
and also his family in the book right
after this event it says her First Act
is Queen was to declare sir on a
Hightower and queen Alison traitors and
Rebels as for my half brothers and my
sweet sister Helena she announced they
have been LED astray by the Council of
evil men let them come to Dragonstone
bend the knee and ask my forgiveness and
I shall gladly spare their lives and
take them back into my heart for they
are my own blood and no man or woman is
as accursed as the kin Slayer again this
idea of kin Slayer pops up again and
Eamonn ends up being called it after
murdering lucerus who was seen as
against brother call to murder someone
who's in envy and also many thought that
killing a relative ended up cursing the
person who did it this is married and
Lara strong who of course murdered his
brother and father after he sent
assassins to their home in Harren Hall
we watch as everyone bends the knee to
her except for Anis who still has to
talk with her husband the table is late
and the swords are prepared as are the
markings one that we see is a high Tower
symbol which contains the burning Beacon
at the top that was talked about at the
wedding they start to plan things out
and bring up Lord Grover Tully who was
mentioned earlier in the season Damon
says he'll go deal with him himself
potentially setting up their meeting in
season two they also mentioned how the
Lannisters won't support an era and I
totally forgot to mention last week that
they were clearly spurned by her
marriage rejection at aegon's second
born day the show didn't cover it but
both her brothers proposed to her and
they basically turn into little bitching
colds after getting rejected that was
that was a good I'll be honest though at
this point Damon and raniero discuss how
their dragons outnumber the greens and
this is the largest section of the
chapter in which they list up all the
ones on their side Damon eventually goes
out scouting for the others on the
island and this includes vermethor now
Verma Thor is the second oldest dragon
in the realm only being a younger De
Vega the dragon actually belonged to
King joharis and it accepted him as his
writer back in 48 AC known as the bronze
Fury this gigantic Beast is a big win
for near his side and Damon sings that
it will have another Rider soon jiharis
died back in 103 AC and thus it's been
about 20 to 30 years since it last had a
rider this cave is called dragon mount
which is where the dragon retreated to
right after his death there's a great
paragraph in the book that talks about
how dragons are not horses it says they
do not easily accept men upon their
backs and when angera threatened they
attack munchkin's true telling tells us
that 16 men lost their lives during the
sowing three times that number were
burned or maimed Stefan darklin was
burned to death while attempting to
mount the dragon sea smoke or Gorman
Massey civil the same fate When
approaching Verma Thor a man called
Silver Dennis whose hair and eyes lent
Credence to his claim that he descended
from a bastard son of make or the cruel
had an arm torn off by sheep stealer as
his sons struggled to staunch the wound
the cannibal descended on them drove off
sheep stealer and devoured his father
and sons alike so yeah very brutal and
eventually Verma Thor does get a rider
who'll likely be shown in season two
alongside him the book gives the names
of all the dragons on Dragonstone his
Vermax arax well for a bit haraxis
maylese Moon Dancer Cyrax and caraxis
there's also Silverwing sea smoke which
belong to Leno and of course Verma Thor
now will be interesting to see if Plano
returns due to the character actually
being dead in the book this would mean
his Dragon could be contested that's
more Theory time or another
[Music]
anyway at this point his ship has
spotted coming in and Eric says I
shipped him to decided offshore a long
Galley and flying a banner of a
three-headed Green Dragon green dragon
obviously to signify the greens and Otto
and Co have come to make a deal this
scene is of course meant to mirror the
confrontation episode 2. everything is
shot in a similar Manner and Cyrax even
lands behind Otto and Co just like how
the dragon did back then whereas raniera
came in to try and stop things
escalating into a civil war here we
actually see it playing out with the
terms and conditions bloody terms and
conditions always get in the way now to
reflect that scene more we have Otto in
attendance he was missing from the book
with it being just Grand maester Orwell
who delivered the parchment they do
pretty much the same thing with
everything being laid out renero is told
that if she accepts aegon is the king
and she'll be allowed to become the lady
of Dragonstone and Luke and keep
driftmark in the work this is delivered
by Orwell and the passage goes ranera
heard these terms in Stony silence and
asked Orwell if you remembered her
father King viserys of course your grace
a maesteran said perhaps you can tell us
who he named this as Aaron's successor
the queen said a crown upon her head you
your grace all will replied and raniera
nodded and said with your own tongue you
admit I am your lawful Queen why then do
you serve my half-brother The Pretender
it said that Allen gave a long and
erudite reply that cited and a law but
mushroom said this didn't happen and
that he just wet himself either way he
was stripped of his chains and these
were given to mace to gyaradis who Ray
described as a trillional servant of the
realm and also its laws the paragraph
Ends by saying that raniera said tell my
half-brother that I will have my Throne
or I will have his head none of this
happens in the entry and another
criticism I've seen on Twitter is that
they've softened rhaenyra a bit for this
season in the book she was also pretty
bad but they have neutered her quite a
lot however I do prefer this in a TV
show as it allows us to gravitate
towards her side and end up rooting for
her I'm guessing after her face at the
end that she'll become more complex in
season 2 but we needed to see her lose a
lot of things before she turned bad
having her stood off like that doesn't
leave room for the growth that we see
and it makes her a flatter character if
she doesn't become twisted over time
interestingly another emission that they
have here is that the source material
had Eric and Eric saying their goodbyes
this was a sort of final farewell before
the war and they both respectfully said
tatibai to each other on the bridge the
idea that two twin brothers would end up
going to opposite sides shows how much
the Civil War really split the realm and
this is of course playing on the idea
that Civil Wars themselves are often
brother versus brother not literally but
you know that's the metaphor that comes
with it and the work says that long
after the dance was done that Lucian of
Tarth would compose a ballad about them
called Farewell My Brother according to
the book this song is sung for
generations and it follows the pair
trying to persuade the other to join
their side in the end they exchanged
Declarations of love and part knowing
that the next time they see each other
that they'll be enemies we don't get it
sad badly and I'm guessing they pulled
it back so we could just keep the focus
on Otto and raniera honor drops a line
pulled directly from the book that goes
over why aegon pretty much fits the idea
of what people view as a king he wears
the conqueror's crown wields the
conqueror's sword has the conqueror's
name now here to show their friendship
raniera is presented with the page of
the book that she tore out in episode 1.
granera even said
what are you doing do you remember and
this embodies the friendship that they
once had I wish we could just go back to
those days of reading under the weirwood
tree instead of people being at War and
constantly on the back foot that's not a
foot joke Laris take your hand out your
pants you're dirty bird a Damon wants
them all killed and even Cyrax ramps up
renira forbids it though and again this
is playing on the idea that you don't
kill envoys the hightowers don't end up
playing by these rules and in the end it
shows why Eamon looks so worried after
vagar goes wild he's basically like
sick
we go back to the council with raniera
warning that if War turns to Dragon vs
dragon that the entire realm will burn
renira doesn't want to rule over a
kingdom of Ash I love the way the
candles are laid out over the table
foreshadowing the Doom that could come
it all kicks off and runira clears the
room so that she can talk to Damon now
raniera brings up the song of ice and
fire oh that Damon wasn't told about
when renero has made the air she was
pretty much told about it straight away
whereas Damon never was this kind of
hints to how much his brother actually
trusted him and though viserys did love
his bro because of the because of the
parchment
the parchments it's clear he knew he'd
be replaced after a while zaris very
much wanted his children to actually be
The Heirs and thus he didn't see any
point in telling him shame seen this
because he's such a nice guy like uh
well except for the the air for a Day
joke and that he killed his wife but
beyond that really nice guy it of course
shows how good the writing and House of
the Dragon is that he can do all this
terrible stuff and still get the
audience to feel for him Matt Smith has
completely nailed the character and even
though I've watched the guy for years
and years I still don't see him I just
see Damon the prophecy is also very much
driving raniera's conflict over this too
the true threat is coming from the North
and the realm must be United and
prepared for whatever it brings if they
are divided it'll be easier for the
white walkers to take over this also
explains why viserys and Joe Harris was
so fixated on peace they too would have
heard the prophecy and had aegon and
Allison then they might not have even
pushed by the Civil War due to the
incoming danger really makes you think
and had this secret been better known
then a lot of this war may have even
been avoided with peace being the
priority cuterini syncolis who have a
bit of a domestic after losing their
children Corliss fled the realm to go to
war and he gets an info dump on what's
gone on they have a really touching
scene and the power couple end up going
to the council where they pledge their
allegiances anyway the work describes
Carlos and rain piece like this the
greatest law to pledge his strength of
the princess was called as Valerian of
driftmark though the sea snake had grown
old he liked to say that he was still
clinging to life like a drowning sailor
clinging to the wreckage of a sunken
ship perhaps the seven may have
preserved me for this one last fight the
Lord callers came his wife princess
rhaenis 5 in 50 but her face lean and
lined her black hair streaked with white
yet Fierce and fearless as she had been
to in 20. the rest of the scene pulls
directly from the book and lays out
everything that happens in this moment
it says and so was decided Prince Damon
would lead the assault on Harren Hall
riding caraxis princess renera would
remain on Dragonstone until she had
recovered her strength the Valerian
Fleet would close off the gullet
sallying forth from Dragonstone and
drift Mark to block all shipping
entering a leaving Blackwater Bay
further seal the gullet we can cut off
all Seabourn travel and trade to King's
Landing after that the Burke then says
then up spoke the Queen's eldest son
jacaris we should bear those men
messages he said dragons will win the
Lord's over quicker than Ravens which
gets altered slightly into this we
should bear those mistress dragons can
fly faster than Ravens
and they're more convincing we then had
raniera say if you go you go as
Messengers not as night you must take no
pardon any fighting not until both boys
had sworn solemn Oaths upon a copy of
the seven-pointed star would her grace
consent to using them as her invoice
this gets adapted in this moment in the
episode if you take this errand you go
as Messengers not as Warriors you must
take no part in any fighting the chapter
ends with a paragraph about aegon's
reaction to an era's refusal it says
aegon II was 2 and 20 quick to anger and
slow to forgive rainer's refusal to
accept Israel enraged him I offered her
an honorable piece and the horse spat in
my face he declared what happens next is
on her own head what happened next was
war or so it says in the book a really
cool way to end a chapter they then fly
out whilst Damon goes to Verma Thor and
sadly this journey is the last time
these dragons will ride alongside each
other now the next part goes into the
dying of the Dragons a son for his son
the first part of the chapter follows
Harris on his mission but to make the
season go out with a bang we instead go
with lucerys his journey was described
as being the shorter safe of flight and
had it gone well then a lot of the grief
would have been averted in the book we
actually follow things mainly from
eamon's side with him arriving at
Storm's end to propose marriage I feel
like Storm's end might have subtext to
it and though it's a location that
existed in the law for centuries we are
seeing a literal storm at the end of I'm
such a [ __ ] idiot now obviously it's
just a coincidence but even the end of
chapter 12 ends with discussing
viserys's death as being an event that
made the storm break before the dragons
danced so yeah I think it's probably all
just a coinkydink but it's still cool
having this as the final battle for the
season as mentioned earlier Lord Borman
had saw loyalty to an Era but Boris was
a totally different Beast Eamonn had
been instructed to offer his hand a
marriage to one of the Lord's daughters
boros told him to choose any of them
that he'd like with Cass being the
oldest that was the first to flower
whilst Flores was prettier cheers that
now according to mushroom he kissed all
of boris's daughters in order to taste
the quote-unquote nectar of their lips
lucerosene arrived which is how we see
it playing out in the episode he was
mocked for wedding himself due to being
soaked and throws boots being damp just
don't take them off around Laris another
thing Boris was most interested in was
getting his daughters married after
powerful houses banned Juda luceras
being betrothed he simply couldn't do
this Eamonn however could due to being
single as a pringle but whether they
went through this or not is something
we're gonna leave for season two now as
we see the book has him demanding an eye
in return for allowingly saris to live
not laughing now are you a [ __ ] now when
lucerus ignored this Eamon went to
attack him but Boris said there wouldn't
be any Bloodshed under his roof as we've
mentioned tons of times lucerus was an
Envy so it would cause a lot of issues
with Boris it's basically the Westeros
version of diplomatic immunity anyway
luceros arrives just as the storm is
about to break which we hear from the
lightning I love how intimidating it is
seeing Vega's head pop over the wall and
you really see how much it dwarfs the
castle luceris delivers the message on a
scroll and a nice little detail here is
that Boris couldn't read so he had to
get a maester in the dialogue he gives
here is pulled straight from the book
with him saying go home pup and tell
your mother that the Lord of storms end
is not some dog that she can whistle up
at need to set against her foes from
this point Eamon says hold strong first
pay the date you owe me Eamonn calls him
is strong in the episode and he wants
the debt repaid obviously now aiming at
this point pulls off his eye patch to
reveal a sapphire stone this is
something that amen would often wear and
it's used to intimidate luceris when in
Cody covered it with an eye patch in
order to not scare the ladies but when
in battle he ended up taking it off you
might have noticed that a sapphire was
actually added to the credit sequence at
the start along with several of the
crowns in sigils marking the new
characters Eamonn does a lot of
smoldering in this bit and then you
could come up with a model post called
blue steel or something anyway Bucyrus
runs out into the storm and we see that
Vega has basically done a Batman and
completely disappeared we don't see
things from aiman's side but the buck
fills in the details with one of boris's
daughters taunting him she says was it
one of your eyes he took or one of your
balls The Impressions get better as the
videos go on now Maris asked the prince
in tone sweet as honey I am so glad you
chose my sister I want a husband with
all his Parts the paragraph then reads
Eamon targaryen's mouth Twisted in Rage
and he turned once more to Lord boros
asking for his leave the Lord of storms
then shrug and answered it's not for me
to tell you what to do when you're not
beneath my roof you're bastard
barathenia burst tooth now later moved
to the side as Prince Ayman rushed to
the doors outside the storm was Raging
Thunder rolled across the castle the
rain fell in blinding sheet and from
time to time great bolts of blue white
lightning lit the world as bright as day
normally aryx was much faster than magar
was but the book spells it out that due
to the storm the larger Dragon was able
to catch her the battle is described as
being spotted by watches on the castle
wall who watched as the dragons met
above shipbreaker Bay distant blasts of
flames were heard along with shrieks in
a thunder I absolutely love the chase
scene and wondering where Vega was
throughout really kept the tension up
such a cool shot singer Fly overhead
completely dwarfing aryx and it appears
and disappears amongst all the clouds I
actually thought they were going to do
some change-ups from The Source material
and have lucera survive it there's a big
shock when he goes down I think this is
basically just a case of two kids that
couldn't control their dragons and this
leads to a lot of issues there's a lot
of comments online about how this neutro
Damon too but I actually think it makes
him far more complicated in Game of
Thrones Jaime Lannister was known as the
king Slayer and he pretty much used this
to his Advantage however that reputation
was something he wrestled over as many
viewed as being cowardly I can't see
Eamon doing the same thing too but I
think he's gonna go back to King's
Landing and brag about it because it's
gonna scare other people however In This
Moment he's pretty much a 20 year old
kid who has a weapon of mass destruction
with no idea what he's doing now there's
people who hate this slight changer but
I really think it gives her more depth
because he knows he's [ __ ] up now
lucerus's death has several accounts to
it with one even being a happy ending
the first one says that Alex and luceris
were swallowed By the stormlashed Waters
of the bay mushroom says that Eamon cut
out his eyes and presented them to Lady
Maris on a bed of seaweed which does
sort of get played upon with his line
about Alison plan to make a gift of it
to my mother
the closest one we get though has Vegas
snatching luceros off his Dragon's Back
and swallowing him whole however the
book says that in truth the prince's
body was never found there was even one
account that said he washed up on the
shore with amnesia he apparently lived
out the rest of his life peacefully and
completely unaware of what happened just
going by as a simple-minded fisherman I
kind of like this as the episode opens
with him talking about not being a
sailor and I if that's what you want to
think happen go for it mate I might even
do it myself either way this actually
ended the sending of Ravens and envoys
due to the peace now being broken the
season ends with Damon delivering the
news to his wife and she turns to the
fire this is of course symbolic as she
didn't want the realm to burn but now
her standing in front of it shows she's
thinking to hell with it let fire rain
down baby an eye for an eye a sun for a
son it's time for us to watch the dance
of the dragons
now that ends the episode and also the
season what an incredible run this has
been and thank you for coming with me on
this journey after the disappointment I
felt with season 8 of Game of Thrones
and never thought I'd find the love for
the property that I once had what about
from the office series set a really high
bar and in my opinion it got better the
longer it went on though I think we
could have spent more time flashing out
certain time periods I still think they
kept the meat of the story and also
diverted it in interesting ways that
were nice changeups from the book rather
than being stupid ones spoilers can
often ruin things but even knowing what
was going to happen I was still
genuinely surprised I think the twists
and turns made this enthralling to watch
and there's definitely some emmy-worthy
performances in here such as Paddy
considine's portrayal of viserys the
level I handle the material ad has set a
really high bar and the most exciting
thing is that this story in the book
only gets better I don't know if this is
my favorite show of the year but it's
definitely up there I think it's
alongside the boys and Better Call Saul
for me for being a series that really
knocked my socks off put your hand away
Alaris put it [ __ ] away say now it
had some slower Pace moments but I was
so interested in the characters that I
didn't really mind I can't wait to
rewatch this from the start and I hope
you've enjoyed the breakdowns now as for
what's gonna happen next time I am going
to be dropping a big season 2 video that
will go over what happens in the books
for the next part of the video we'll be
going over what happens for some of the
next part and this won't be any major
Revelations but it'll probably be what
happens in the first episode of season
two anyway if you don't want to know
please turn off now still yeah cool so
okay so Eamonn actually returns home and
he basically boasts that he's killed
luceris this doesn't go down too well
with Alison though who's completely
shocked over it however aegon ends up
celebrating on the other side of this
Damon promises his son for a son and he
goes to my zarya for help we've already
broken down the blood and cheese Saga
several times so I don't want to keep
going over it but if you want to know
about it in depth then check out our
horrifying moment video which will be
linked at the end anyway my zarya hires
two assassins that sneak into the castle
and they end up killing aegon's eldest
Sonja Harris this starts a war of
escalation in which the two houses do
whatever they can to try and murder the
others as for jiserus which is how I
think the season will open we go to
Winterfell and he becomes really good
mates with his stocks he apparently also
falls in love with a woman called Sarah
snow which though said to be a complete
fabrication is something they could
bring to the show either way that's
that's what happens next time and that's
also the video now there's lots to talk
about with the season and drop your
comments below it's been a great 10
weeks with you guys and we will be
dropping more House of the dragon videos
over the next coming weeks so make sure
you stick around now we are running in
competition right now and giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of November and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe the
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your general thoughts and
everything as I said the blood and
cheese video will be linked on screen
right now so if you want to know more
about that then head over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video really
appreciate you sitting to this point
hope you enjoy the rest of your week
mate take care yourself peace
[Music]